thank you
it's 10 o'clock this is Sky News at 10
our top story how Russia fell back from
the Ukrainian front line we meet the
soldiers pushing forwards near back mud
it's the crackler machine gun in the
distance
the Russian positions are not far away
from here we're now entering the area
the ukrainians took from them
a few days ago
we see inside the trenches abandoned by
Russian soldiers as the Ukrainian forces
tell us they've made an awesome advance
and we're not going away Rishi sunak
tells president zelenski as he promises
more weapons though not the Jets Ukraine
seeks
also tonight's driving prices higher at
the pump the warning to supermarkets
over petrol and Diesel from the
competition watchdog
the military planes flying into the
sunset but we hear why some in the
forces say it will leave the UK
dangerously exposed
Prince Harry the hacking case and the
witnesses who allege listening into
voicemails was bulk standard at the
mirror newspapers
and we'll take a first look at
tomorrow's front pages in our press
preview from 10 30.
[Music]
hello very good evening for months the
battle for bakmut has symbolized a
grinding stalemate of the war in Ukraine
in recent days though that has changed
with Russian forces falling back from
the front line near the city tonight we
have a report from that front line our
International correspondent and his team
seeing the trenches and foxholes
abandoned by President Putin's soldiers
and that on the day that Rishi sunak
told Russia and his guest Vladimir
zelenski that the UK isn't going away
well the first selling of bakmut took
place on May the 17th last year since
last week the Ukrainian military has
started to push Russian forces back in
and around it their first significant
offensive operations since November Alex
Rossi reports from Southwest of bakmut
after months of setbacks on the back
move fronts they are advancing as the
weather improves
we joined the third Brigade and they
wanted to show us how they're forcing
the Russians back
the fighting here remains Fierce and the
last few hundred meters towards the new
front line have to be made on foot
across open grounds
you can hear in the distance the sound
of small arms fire
the crackler machine gun in the distance
the Russian positions are not far away
from here we're now entering the area
that the ukrainians took from them
a few days ago
foreign
down here is one of the foxholes that
they were in inside you can see Russian
clothing boots
and everything that they left behind
when this was cleared out
these scratches of Woodland have been
decimated by shrapnel and gunfire
what should be fields of wheat are
pockmarked by the constant shelling
this footage from a helmet camera shows
how the Brigade cleared these areas
infantry using grenades and storming the
positions
some of the Russians fled chased Away by
Bullet and shell
others were captured but many were
killed here in the fighting
is
and as we were leaving they were still
collecting the bodies of Russian
soldiers from the battlefields
horany
attack
foreign
s here are a Prelude to Ukraine's coming
counter-offensive it could start any day
now
and at the brigades headquarters they
scan the landscape for Russian movements
but despite Ukraine's success in recent
days Russia still controls 90 of back
moves
they show us a drone live stream of the
city
and the damage is horrific
this place is now a smoking ruin
the soldiers here though are confident
they can win back their country but any
Victory will take time
we know what we are doing we know how we
must uh doing uh
our attack or our defense we know that
in the end maybe two three five years I
don't know we will win this world
announcer offensive comes is still a
guessing game even for the troops on the
grounds
but they know their time is coming
and they say they are ready
Alex Rossi Sky News on the back boot
fronts
our International correspondent there on
the front line well the setting could
hardly have been a greater contrast to
the mud and Devastation in eastern
Ukraine Rishi sunak welcomed president
zielinski today to Checkers the 16th
century manor house and Prime
ministerial Retreat there he told
Ukraine's leader the UK would continue
providing support and that he would work
with other countries on providing Jets
our International Affairs editor Dominic
wackall reports from checkers
in the country Retreats where Winston
Churchill spent so much of the war a
welcome for a man now so often compared
to him president zielinski was flown by
military helicopter to Checkers for a
surprise visit ending a Whistle Stop
tour of Europe greeted and honored by
the Prime Minister Winston Churchill
made many of his famous speeches in
World War II from this room and in the
same way today your leadership your
country's bravery and fortitude are an
inspiration to us all there was plenty
of symbolism and a place steeped in
Wartime history and some substance
Promises of attack drones and more
missiles but president zielinski is
warning allies without more support his
military's long-awaited
counter-offensive could be delayed we're
only in need some some more time not too
much and there was yet another plea for
Ukraine to be sent Western warplanes
today we spoke about the Jets very
important topic for us because we can't
control the sky we want to create these
uh Jets Coalition and I'm very positive
with it we spoke about it and I see that
in the closest time you will hear some
well the two leaders were meeting in
Moscow the Kremlin angrily condemned the
military package Britain's announced its
giving
I guess
with itself
comments that were dismissed by the
Prime Minister I think it's important
for the Kremlin to also know that we're
not going away
right we are here for the long term we
remain steadfast in wanting to defend
Ukraine not just now to reclaim its
rightful territory but also to ensure
that Ukraine has a mean to defend itself
into the future as well Ukraine is still
keeping the world guessing about its
long awaited counter-offensive and well
it will begin and the longer that wait
goes on the more doubts will grow about
its ability to wage it effectively
from the eidetic beauty of the English
Countryside president zielinski flies
back to a war-torn country the promises
of Europe's leaders ringing in his ears
promises he's heard before but is still
no closer to Victory Dominic wyghorn Sky
News at checkers
well the UK has provided more military
aid to Ukraine than any other country
bar America but it's been in stages and
Ukraine wants more and now our security
and defense analyst Professor Michael
Clarke explains why
after months of stalemate things are
starting to happen in this war Alex
Rossi reported for on the new phase of
this battle for back but concentrating
in the South where the ukrainians are
pushing hard to keep the access road
open and like in all battles it feels
pretty complicated and dangerous to
those on the ground and further north
the ukrainians have also been making
some inroads against Russian positions
and for the Russians the fear must be
that they could be encircled behind back
much if they don't rush some reserves
built to North and to South to prevent
it
but of course this is only one small
section of a Battlefront that is
potentially over 600 miles long now we
don't know where the main Ukrainian
punch may come but the Russians clearly
think that it might come in the South
because they're building some very big
defenses shown here in red they
obviously think that they've got
something really important to defend in
that southern area
any Ukrainian offensive is only possible
with the help of the West and the latest
figures up to the end of February show
over 75 billion pounds worth of Aid has
been committed 75 billion and the UK has
given the second most of that total so
there's a lot of it but it's all coming
stages now and again dribs and drabs are
some say it which is less than ideal
the UK has taken a very positive
attitude but just look at the number of
individual announcements that we have
made in the 14 months since the War
Began there were only four months where
we didn't make one announcement often
two and in one case even four
announcements all in one month and these
announcements were all separate
announcements of discrete packages of
military aid that we intended to give
and the point the ukrainians keep making
is if the Western only committed earlier
and more clearly what they were prepared
to do then they the ukrainians would now
be in a very different position
however we are where we are
we think that the ukrainians have around
12 maybe up to 16 brigades of infantry
mechanized infantry and most importantly
armor brigades and the way these
elements work together and are used by
Ukraine will be the key in the coming
months to their success or lack of it
and for all of this the Ukraine is still
say they need Western Jets
they feel that that air superiority and
they're not wrong about this will decide
who will win in any given battle space
now some Western politicians think that
zielinski is actually crying wolf over
the f-16s
I guess we'll find out pretty soon
whether he is or not
what we saw here is eyewitness reports a
little earlier in the program and
tonight Alex Rossi is in cremator skin
eastern Ukraine now Alex from what
you've seen is Ukraine ready for this
big push
well certainly I think along the back
moot's line of contact it stretches for
absolutely miles they are buoyed by the
successes they are limited successes we
should stress over recent days but the
fighting around back moot has been
really the most ferocious of this war
back moves itself is really a symbol for
the the horror of this conflict but the
fact that they have had success there
Has Lifted morale it's lifted Spirits
because they think they can have
breakthroughs elsewhere they're also
buoyed by the fact that they have
Western weapons coming into the country
many of the troops are returning after
being trained by uh Western Powers as
well so they think they can do it and
this is important the fact that they
have been able to move forwards here
after months of setbacks but they do
also warn that this counter-offensive
it's not going to be a Magic Bullet that
you're unlikely to see a full collapse
of the Russian military there's no sense
really that Vladimir Putin wants to end
this war and Russia has huge reserves of
materiel and troops so they do say that
even if it is successful this walk could
still continue not just for many months
but many years
Alex many thanks Alex Rossi there in
Ukraine
State media in Belarus have shown a
video tonight after reports that
President Putin's closest Ally was
unwell the pictures show President
Alexander lukashenko who had not been
seen in public for a week a photo of the
leader was also published by a state
news channel
back here the sky high prices for petrol
and Diesel since the beginning of the
war in Ukraine could have been lower the
competition regulator concluded today it
said there was evidence of weakening
competition in the market for fuel
driven mainly by the big supermarkets
our business correspondent gurpreet
narwan reports everyone is counting the
cost
not least motorists who have been
exposed to high oil prices because of
the war in Ukraine
but are they paying more than necessary
the competition regulator the CMA has
accused supermarkets of increasing their
margins on fuel at a time when
households are feeling the pinch we have
seen evidence that suggests that this
isn't entirely due to factors outside of
retailers control and in particular what
we've seen is some evidence that at
least one retailer has taken an internal
decision to increase their margin
targets and that other retailers have
become aware of that and and may have
adjusted their conduct accordingly in
its investigation the competition
regulator found that Supermarket fuel
margins have increased from under four
people per liter in 2017 to over 10
people per liter in 2022
this is the product of a year-long
investigation that still has some time
to run but the competition regulator
hasn't had an easy time of it it accused
supermarkets of being uncooperative
saying that they were insufficiently
forthcoming with the evidence
so it will now interrogate management
hauling them in for interviews to get to
the bottom of what's going on
the supermarkets say their prices remain
competitive and that they're trying
their best to Shield customers from the
effects of rampant inflation but
campaign groups are skeptical the
biggest retailers have a lot to answer
and that's why there's going to be
interviews with the CMA coming up if you
go to Northern Ireland where the
supermarkets don't have such a big hold
but wholesale the price of diesel is far
cheaper and fuel generally is cheaper
than the rest of the UK so if
something's not working properly it's
not just fuel prices that have raised
eyebrows with food prices jumping at a
rate of almost 20 percent the
competition regulator is also scanning
the aisles for unfair price increases
so far it's found nothing unreasonable
but it's keeping a close eye on the
supermarkets they will not be able to
get away with using inflation as an
excuse for profiteering
gabri nawan Sky News
the defense secretary insisted today
that the military's new Transport
Aircraft Fleet outperforms the planes
it's replacing after multiple defense
sources said the move will leave the UK
dangerously exposed the C-130 aircraft
used most recently in the airlift from
Sudan is being withdrawn from service
Sky security and defense editor Deborah
Haynes reports
as last month's Sudan crisis mounted the
Royal Air Force's transport Fleet
mobilized
here a C-130 Hercules loads up Marines
to help with evacuations
the aircraft can also be used by Special
Forces
but it's being retired next month to cut
costs even as security threats grow
this is where the c-130s are based
alongside a replacement Fleet of newer
larger and more capable aircraft called
the atlas a400m
still the local MP is worried they're a
niche C-130 capabilities that still need
to be transferred onto a400 a400 has
serviceability and reliability
availability concerns and even leaving
that aside even if that weren't the case
there are fewer airframes now than there
would have been before the urgent need
to evacuate British Nationals from Sudan
saw c-130s and a400s flying back and
forth from an air base in Cyprus the Sky
News data and forensics unit identified
three c-130s involved in the mission
they made 1930s and evacuated more than
700 people four a400 seem to have taken
part flying 22 trips and evacuating more
than 1700 people internal documents also
reveal that as of the 5th of may just
one out of seven of the C-130 fleet was
listed as out of action that two-thirds
of the raf's 21 a400s were unserviceable
or unavailable now
in just a matter of weeks these c-130s
as well as the rest of the fleet will no
longer be based here at Bryce Norton
instead they'll be up for sale to be
bought by other countries given they've
still got many more years worth of
flying in them an RAF Source said to me
scrapping the C-130 is probably one of
the worst military decisions the UK has
made in the post-world War era
responding to the sky news report the
defense secretary dismissed what he
described as tired arguments the l400i
performs the hurt on most types it's got
a longer range bigger capacity you can
land in the same area in fact can land
in shorter distance the Hercules only
accounts for 10 of the fleet and the
overall Fleet for Lyft is now the
biggest it's been for 50 years
but selling the C-130 Fleet still
inevitably makes the UK's capability to
transport troops and rescue civilians
smaller debraham Sky News
Prince Harry isn't due to give evidence
in the high court hacking trial of
mirror group newspapers until next month
barter journalist seen as close to the
sussexes made a major claim in the case
today Omi scoby said that while on work
experience at the papers he heard then
editor Piers Morgan take part in a
conversation which made reference to
hacked voicemails and calls Katie
Spencer was at the high court and her
report contains flash photography
first to give evidence in Prince Harry's
case against mirror group newspapers
Harry and Megan's biographer and a
former journalist at the Sunday Mirror
Dan Evans given a suspended sentence
back in 2014 after admitting illegal
information gathering at the now defunct
news of the world but a journalist
before that at the Sunday Mirror hired
in 2003 to work for then editor Tina
Weaver in court he said it was a badly
kept secret that he was the designated
in-house hacker using burner phones in
her office to keep his work largely out
of sight of The Newsroom
mgn denies voicemail in section at any
of its titles but in court Evan said he
was doing it and had about a 30 success
rate claiming that when he was at the
paper in his words he was doing dodgy
stuff on every story
when asked by mgn's legal team if that
was overstating it he said no a lot of
stuff had dodgy goings on insisting it
was so bog standard to do something
dodgy along the line on a story
the Duke of Sussex will be the star
witness in this case but also in court
the author of this book
journalist Omid Scobee who when Accused
by mgn lawyers of having a vested
interest in giving evidence said it
would actually make his life more
difficult but he desperately tried to
move away from allegations he's friends
with the couple and that this thing
wouldn't help
but he spoke of Howe when he started out
on work experience at the mirrors
entertainment desk in 2002 he heard it's
then editor Piers Morgan asked how
confident the team was in reporting a
story about Kylie Minogue and someone
she was dating he said the conversation
was they had broken up there was
reference made to voicemails and calls
they'd made to each other and this
journalist knew details peers seemed
reassured by this
evidence from the prince's biographer
ahead of the royal himself coming to
court next month mirror group newspapers
insisting its journalists did nothing
wrong Casey Spencer Sky News
[Music]
president erdogan's 20 years at the top
of Turkish politics looks likely to
continue he came out top in the
country's elections this weekend though
with just over 49 of the vote fell short
of being re-elected without a runoff
election whatever the result in two
weeks time it will leave a country
divided as our Europe correspondent Adam
Parsons now reports from the Turkish
capital Ankara
president erdogan started the
celebrations early last night he is
close to winning but he's not there yet
the election campaign will finish with a
runoff but erdogan will be the clear
favorite after taking nearly half the
popular vote
he said we strongly believe that we will
continue to serve our nation for the
next five years
the runoff will be against Kamal
kalistarolo who released a short video
saying his supporters were all in his
heart and that he would fight to the end
but this could be the kingmaker the
Nationalist sin on Iran who got more
than five percent in the election that's
nearly 3 million votes he told me he
will endorse someone but he expects a
ministerial job in return because
this has been a bruising and divisive
campaign and it's got another Fortnight
to run
this election has uncovered some
profound scars in Turkish Society the
difference is based on yes politics but
also culture social background religion
and of course geography whoever wins and
it will probably be president erdogan is
going to have to decide whether they
unite this nation or simply rule it
certainly people are polarized in their
opinions about erdogan this election is
really a referendum on him
will do everything by Democratic way you
think he might cheat huh
I think
election observers say erdogan holds an
unfair Advantage but their criticism
won't really disturb him the second
round is already looming the president
one of the great survivors of global
politics is the favorite to win again
Adam Parson Sky News Ankara
there's some sad news coming out of New
Zealand tonight at least six people have
been killed after a fire broke out at a
hostel police say a number of people are
still believed to be unaccounted for
following the fire at the four-story
building in the capital Wellington that
officers remain at the scene at loafers
Lodge hostel on Adelaide Road where the
fire broke out in the early hours of
this morning
in 10 days time official data is
expected to confirm a big rise in net
migration into the UK today the Home
Secretary said those numbers need to be
lower but the question is where could
the cut come the largest number of visas
granted last year was to students but
official data shows they brought nearly
20 billion pounds of benefit to the
country our data and forensics
correspondent Tom Cheshire has this
report
it wasn't a warm welcome from Extinction
Rebellion protesters for the Home
Secretary
once they've been chucked out suela
bravman said she wanted to welcome
rather fewer legal immigrants we need to
get overall immigration numbers down
and we mustn't forget how to do things
for ourselves
the Home Secretary was speaking in
Westminster on just the other side of
the Thames Lambeth is home to many of
those who make up the biggest source of
legal migration International students
we spoke to two who are planning on
staying to work in the UK after their
studies finish it's quite sad
studying so hard and having such amazing
results at University that it would kind
of it would definitely not be the same
without them I think if it's something
that is discouraging for students to
come you'd feel like it's less of a
welcoming environment especially as an
immigrant after a lull because of the
pandemic Visa grants have surged back
sponsored study visas and visas given to
their dependents are the largest chunk
shown in Brown
the question is how much of a long-term
difference that makes
for example more than 220 000 people
were issued a sponsored study Visa in
2011. a decade later only 13 percent of
them remained in the UK fewer than 30
000.
and in the meantime students bring in a
huge amount of money to the treasury
higher education related exports the
vast majority of which is international
students paying fees in the UK were
worth 19.5 billion pounds in 2021.
that's not much less than exports for
the entire British pharmaceutical sector
last year and it's even more than
Aerospace exports 15.2 billion in 2021
we've been focusing on students because
it's such a large part of the total and
it shows some of the complexity because
usually when we talk about immigration
it's in terms of just a number and
usually for the politicians talking
about it that number is too big but this
touches almost every industry and it
raises the question of what sort of
economy do we want the UK to be
the halls of power will have to take
into consideration the student Halls of
Lambeth and a lot else besides Tom
Cheshire Sky News South London